こんにちははじめ雪をでこんな場所でやることじゃないんですけどもみなさん
ブーメランで知っていますでしょうか
ただあそんなことなくても見たことある人に言うんですか投げると
もどって来るんですよ
理想は子なんでがブーメランだそんなことあるんですけども戻ってくることなんてもう
ないんですよ下手な人がなければピョンでとか言っちゃうだけなんですけどなぜ今回私
ブーメラ来なくなりたいと思ってフォームの確認も含めて教室内であるんですけども
後々ストでやろうかと思って多分なんですけどかなりの確率で紛失する恐れがあるので
こちら大量のブーム等購入いたしました
このたくさんのブーメランでこうなんかね投げて投げて投げて集めてっていうかの効率
きゃって今回ブーメランを1万回投げると俺が上手くなるのかまぁ理想は投げて完璧に
戻ってくるのはもう百発百中できるくらい上手くなりたいんですけども一番回もやると
もっと上手くなんかね
投げたら8の字帰って帰ってくるとかあの投げたら120分空中タイプして戻ってくる
とかからそこまで行けた
いいなと思うんですけどもまぁとりあえず1万回頑張って投げてみようと思います練習
前はこんな感じですどうぞ
[音楽]
ハイチュウだけでまずば練習前私のブーメランてくれないお見せしましょう
運動音痴体がないと売れないと思ういきます
投げ方をしっかり見てランドなどを聞き立ててなければいいっぽい
[音楽]
aodea 先なないぞ
ああああああ
ちょっと体育館でてるんだけど風もないずジっぽいすねーなるだろう
北極
car
[音楽]
風ねっとダメなんかなちょっと立ててなきゃだけのパターン3が下げています
おっバッハ
うんやはいはい
普通ないでやるまずねーそこの変だと注油するんですかもう
チェイン数
[音楽]
なんかが金座使ってきたけどさっきブーメランの裏見て海とか行かずに向かってな
気取ってるんです
[音楽]
えっでちょっと押しが良かったらいい
えっマット技術だよっっ
すごいスペースいい
[音楽]
yeah 今だよ3つほぼ同じでも期待され
ん
ちょっとだけだね
ちょっと試合数だけあの室内でやっててもクーラーは意味がないあぜがあって戻って
くるようになるので外でちょっと練習してきたいと思いますです午前回を投げました
replay
[音楽]
おっおおっををよはよ餌近いぞ
[拍手]
青シールん
[音楽]
これは戻ってきた初めて俺だぁキャッチできればカッコいいってことでそうだ
だった
ああああああ
[音楽]
170クエで結構マッチテーマ安定してきました
その小西晃治ませんすごい
[音楽]
おおおっ
ここだはぁ
配置や外で時は200回で終了をしておきますちょっと10個だと少なかったね
ちょっともっとたくさん買って一気に回数稼ぎたいのとハゼの重要性を築きました4名
がだいぶ安定して運転の場所に映るようになったんだけど結局かですね良い風が吹い
たりと戻ってこない
最後に興味100回投げてみた別よく試してみたいと
[音楽]
をした俊英そういう2回目なんですけどもう前回
運勢前回がブーメラ10個でやってたんですけどもうそれの遅すぎるや改善率が悪
すぎるということでこちら
滑ら4図5個に増やしました
想像増えましたね目卵1個結構ただ湯煎以上するんでもうこれでだいたい
種5万ぐらいは使ってます早速今日も練習していきましょう
者は良い
あああああもう吸い寄せ陽水
[音楽]
436回目で風が弱いので投球フォームについたような感じになります
481回目行きまーす良い子たちが釣れ投げるその方がおかしくなってきました
頑張りやす
[音楽]
pore
ee
あのだ4日酔い俺も3年前両小屋いいですよバイバイ
はい今日頑張っていきましょう501回目からです
[音楽]
ああ
あー入ってきパワーを約20軒良い始めて帰ってきましたーー
ようやく1回目です
511回目す
アップライト型カフェの牛のがコツです
636透明からいきます
ええええええ
681回できます
goo
嘘見せてあげて卓球
じゃあねーく26かねぇ
[音楽]
はいという発言で言ってがーです今日も頑張っていきましょう
me
阿部拓さままだ経ちの風強くて掃除ません
けど攻撃を含めてぶー目立ってしっかりの効果で多様性を投げていきましょう
[音楽]
ひろっぱねぇ
ああああああああああああっ
どこどこどこ見え見え
800型ずいっと目です
[音楽]
消える初1投目です良いよ戦闘目に入りますその戦闘名どんなが前あればきっと
みましょう
[音楽]
あっはぁ
まず彼に届かないぐらいです
[音楽]
ええええええ
ていた
全71頭目です
tee
car
ええええええ
par
釣りや左右遺体を振ってるんだぞん
良い子 dna
ええええええ
san
エグジットでいきまーす
汗に与え終了です今日プールにしてみましょうあざっす肇社長ですと技で12001回
目からやっていこうと思いますね時子ちゃまに戻ってきてキャッチする時腕痛いんで
そろそろ軍でつけて本格的にやっていこうかと思います頑張ってみましょう
[音楽]
だろ4もう今すぐと訪れすっ
パフォーマンスやヴァイス月ん
ええええええ
景気があっやばいあっぱれだぞ
俺じゃないけどん
1290ミット名
[音楽]
me
いやーバサッ
待ってっこれおります
ごと一投目です
[音楽]
1500頭目終わりました自分で投げやすい風を好きはうまく投げるんですけど本当の
急に投げる時に風邪入れ替わったりすると結構戻って来です敗戦後4ビット目ですだけ
ていきましょう
[音楽]
パパスタッフ
これだ
[音楽]
ana
ただザッツせなねフィット目
[音楽]
そのラインと高かった
やばーい
数18001回目です今日も頑張っていきましょうマジでねあの熱すぎて普通に外に出
ちゃいけんレベルの暑さんですけども曲げ自動頑張って京都ば1番だ
[音楽]
電源フィットネス
1905ずいっとねこのままに戦までいきますほんのさっきなんですけども上げるコツ
をなんか使うな気がします
頑張ります
これです
[音楽]
はっはっは
以前会終わりました
全風の軌道が変わるやっぱりちょっとうまくいかないございます20001投目です匡
宏ロケでだけていこうと思います
よっしゃっちゃ
ですし
[音楽]
club ark
危ないん
ana
bes はテラス2100磯部です
[音楽]
me
ん
犠牲500回思い出した4分の1です
熱中症ですね含まず大調理師
頑張ります
どうぞ
あっはぁ
ます
だ
ha
ます
風がそう僕で
[音楽]
と船や部屋ゲー
あった
いやーヤバイって言っ
不当これだ2,900回終わったところで暗くなりすぎると見えなくなることが分かり
ました
に整形ビット目
阿部
ええええええ
いいします
[音楽]
ん
ハイ3前回の下終りましたあんなに戻ってくるようになったんですけどもやっぱり凸
同じ事知ってる気がするいけないってみましょうか
[音楽]
tee
ってぐらいですねー
頑張ります3000 it 目です
[音楽]
えっ
th
ています
ます
can you do
se
[音楽]
ん
すー
ana
[音楽]
もう痛くて止め
ます
3種
th
3年後に電池
[音楽]
あああぶねー
進みハーって java 演出した
[音楽]
ていません
びっくりっ
[音楽]
今日風が安定してるんですけど見てこのだった地点
このほぼをなぜバスになっか数字をやって言ってるんで投げれフォーンが結構安定して
きている気がします
まあ風によりますけど
me
ピュッ
対処の各3801ん
[音楽]
wh
多分ん
t 4
p 4
ええええええ
ん
[音楽]
タンディ寄付図1番激励 ree
はいはい
はい
ああああああ
dee
入っという気で4000回だけましたカフェレイパー激しいと全然投げれないですね
40001回目です
[音楽]
[拍手]
怖い怖い怖い自分の声自分が怖い
キモッん
th
[音楽]
い
th
[音楽]
飯田さんん
俳優であるんです
[音楽]
4401いっ
持っています
[音楽]
4世のれビーチいい
san to j
楊ぜん751
[音楽]
しています
強い強い売買くれたんです
[音楽]
めっちゃ上で5000会終わりました
どんげないかな2ヶ月ぐらいかかりましたね
夏がウォッチ舞いました一番会はずっと
目だがは捨てたができるなこれ5000回も相当ねえっこすけが見つけて出世つなげた
んですけどやっぱ夏だと1万回は無理でしたね
というわけでちょっと1回この動画は5000回で終わらせていただきたいと思います
あのもちろん一番がやるんですけどちょっとねなく
音がすぐには出せないんでまぁ前編ということで全く部分なんて来なかった男が
5000通ったらどれくらい変わるのが一発勝負でお見せしたいと思います
ご覧ください
ていますね
入ってる
[音楽]
voodoo
られてるよハッハッハ
ただしいって趣味
ni
この度は私の軽率な鳥谷じゃあ
can you バーン
トッティ仕掛けるマジェビビってるん
タイの1尾種類で全然喋らない